mondiale emmanuel macron a fait de la
politique avec un grand p c'est à dire
qu'il s'est intéressé aux affaires du
monde et de façon assez inquiétant de
voir alarmiste écouter l'extrait du
discours qu'il a prononcé hier c'était
au forum de l'apec utilisé par les
retours des passions tristes le
nationalisme le racisme l'antisémitisme
l'extrémisme qui remettent en cause cet
horizon que nos peuples attendent
alors est ce que cette comparaison est
opportune s qu'effectivement on sert la
cause de la paix en dénonçant les
nationalismes et bien avant d'ouvrir le
débat
je vous propose d'écouter ce point de
vue intéressant celui de luc ferry le
philosophe et l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale
il était ce matin sur la matinale de
radio classique le figaro et en
réfléchissant au nationalisme il ya
cette intervention qui commence par une
analyse politique et qui se termine par
une grosse claque à emmanuel macron
regarde il ya le nationalisme français
qui est un universalisme et donc quand
un henri guaino un à droite ou un jean
pierre chevènement à gauche où quentin
régis debray ou un alain finkielkraut
défendent aujourd'hui les frontières ou
les des nations c'est pas dans l'optique
de la haine de l'autre ce sont des
universalistes réduire le nationalisme à
la haine de l'autre est une absurdité
donc on peut pardonner dans la bouche
d'un d'un romain gary parce que c'est
dans un contexte où il a fait une guerre
effroyable contre eux le nationalisme
aux nazis c'est ça qu'il vise
mais leur dire aujourd'hui que c'est
tout simplement une bêtise maurice
szafran c'est une bêtise de absolument
pas une bêtise
vous disiez faire progresser la paix
pendant ce week-end évidemment que non
mais il a posé il a posé les bonnes
questions on a légitimement un le droit
de les poser et deux de penser
qu'effectivement dans un certain nombre
de pays dans un nombre de régimes en
europe et ailleurs il ya effectivement
un retour des patients triste un retour
du nationalisme et non pas du
patriotisme
moi en tout cas dans mon éducation on
m'a expliqué y compris dans les écoles
de la république que le patriotisme et
nationalisme ça n'avait rien à voir il y
à un retour du racisme il ya autour de
lancer mutisme ce sont des vraies
questions et je ne vois pas au nom de
quoi le présent débat public -si
il le pense je suis absolument certain
qu'il est totalement sincère je ne vois
pas au nom de quoi il n'aurait pas le
droit 1-2 de poser ses questions et de
le dire on a le droit de donner le droit
de craquer totalement mais mais mais il
a tout à fait et c'est son rôle de dire
ce qu'il a dit hier complètement
elisabeth la vie est ce que vous
partagez ce diagnostic
alors que rossi passe la main d'abord je
voudrais dire ah bon mais c'est un
rapport être mon propos que moi j'ai été
très touché par la ferveur des gens je
veux dire dans cette commémoration dans
l'idée qu'on célébrait d'abord on ne l'a
pas beaucoup dit quand même une victoire
de la france
et si vous voulez je pense que on peut
en dire beaucoup de choses mais renvoyer
tout le monde dos à dos en permanence et
faire comme si il ya déjà eu des
affrontements armés à lapin me paraît
pas c'est pas en effaçant même le
souvenir de la guerre voilà mais bon là
dessus avait conseillé sur le diagnostic
parce que je pense que ça ne prend pas
la mesure de cela c'est à dire que macro
ne prend pas la mesure de la force de la
force incroyable de l'amour pour son
pays
de ce sentiment que moi j'appelle le
sentiment national parce que dans ce
qu'il appelle le nationalisme si vous
voulez et oui parce que moi je ne crois
que dans ce qu'il appelle le
nationalisme je ne vois pas moi
aujourd'hui la poursuite un continuum
avec le nationalisme d'autre les deux
guerres il n'y a pas de partie de la
guerre mâcon le retour des patients
traités en parle tout le temps moi marc
dons peuvent être faites
je suis trop longue si d'accord je vois
juste aussi une volonté des peuples de
l'expression d'une volonté des peuples
de rester des peuples je ne vois pas une
haine
si vous voulez des autres pays je vois
tout simplement que leur aide supra
nationale de maquereaux si vous voulez
qu'il est derrière tous ces propos sur
l'europe
c'est au raid se heurte à
l'anthropologie et je crains qu'il n'en
prennent pas la meute lyon voilà je vois
moi surtout j'ai peur que ça aboutisse à
une façon de dénoncer les peuples et de
mettre dans le même sac
toute personne qui aura une critique ou
une appréhension sur les flux
migratoires sera mise dans le même sac d
chaude et raciste et homophobe et c est
ça ça nous attend alors évidemment point
de vue étant votre émission nous vous
posons la question sur twitter macron
at-il selon vous fait progresser la
peste en pointant ce sujet ou bien de
courtrai est ce qu'il a exacerbé les
tensions alors ce n'est pas un sondage
associant un mode les gens qui sont en
train de vous regarder et qui est qu'ils
s'expriment mais vous êtes plutôt
critique un globalement et voici
quelques commentaires qui accompagnent
ces votes
sébastien qui sur twitter nous dit macro
n'a pas compris qu'on ne construit pas
la paix en désignant des ennemis en quoi
aurait-il fait progresser la paix nous
demande le bigot sur twitter au
contraire refus de répondre aux
questions liées à l'identité migrants
islam banlieue alors même si c'est vrai
que ce n'était pas tout à fait le thème
de la de la journée d'hier et sur le
chat du figaro nicole nous dînons macro
ne fait pas progresser la paix il oppose
les gens en permanence effectivement sa
sonate c'est à cette alternative pardon
que nous pensions en choisissant ce
titre nicolas bouzou qu'est ce que vous
pensez c'est à dire est-ce que et
magnoac on ne dresse pas un peu les pays
les uns contre les autres avec ce genre
de demain je vais vous dire moi je suis
plutôt d'accord avec l'idée générale des
manuels macron pas avec les comparaisons
historiques pas avec les comparaisons
historiques normes et avec le
nationalisme et je vais vous dire le
fond de ma pensée
mais vraiment je le dis avec prudence
parce que je veux pas choquer mais
certain nombre de mes amis y compris
qu'ils sont sur le sur le plateau et on
respecte éminemment la pensée bien
évidemment mais je n'aime pas le
nationalisme
je suis né en france j'en suis très
heureux mais je n'y suis absolument pour
rien j'aurai la même valeur si j'étais
né en allemagne et je pense que la
grandeur d'un être humain c'est de
s'arracher à ses origines et donc pour
des raisons philosophiques
je n'ai jamais aimé le nationalisme en
revanche considéré que le nationalisme
aujourd'hui celui d' or ban celui de
poutine celui de trump nous mène à la
guerre je pense que c'est absolument
faux je me sens absolument pas menacée
par ces peuples là quand je lis un
discours de victor badges et des
désaccords quasiment sur tout mais
évidemment je
n'est pas du tout le sentiment qu'il met
au style en tant que français que la
hongrie va déclarer la guerre à la
france ça me pose des sujets qui sont
des problèmes qui sont beaucoup plus
concret qui sont beaucoup plus
intéressants sur les structures de
l'union européenne par exemple et là on
a un débat qui est très intéressant et
qu'il faut poser voyez donc je réponds
vraiment avec prudence mais je comprends
ce que veut dire emmanuel macron on a
aussi le droit je sais que l'idée de
nation redevient très à la mode je
comprends parfaitement ça mais comprenez
bien que avec un raisonnement
philosophique que je pense assez solide
on a le droit de ne pas aimer nationale
c'est une phrase c'est pas une idée qui
redevient à la mode je pense que c'est
une force motrice dont on aurait la même
perdu le sens de l'existence tellement
elle est important de se dire c'est que
politiquement politiquement les
gouvernements qui ont le vent en poupe
sont des gouvernements qui sont
favorables à cette idée c'est ce que je
voudrais pas que ça existe si vous
voulez c'est ça que jamais personne
personne n'a jamais dit je suis d'accord
avec nicolas personne n'a jamais pensé
il faudrait être fou que organes met en
danger la france où les alentours que sa
vie ni dans la mer celle d'emmanuel
maman que je suis sûr qu'elles le
pensent mais lui-même et a tellement
aimé un cheval de ce qu'on se dit autour
de sa table
par contre on peut repenser profondément
que pour le peuple hongrois même s'il a
été élu de façon parfaitement
démocratique
je ne supporte plus cette idée de parce
que un responsable politique quel qu'il
soit a été élu par son peuple bien sûr
qu'il était vu par son peu hors bâle n'a
pas fait putsch et les fascistes en
italie n'ont fait aucun putsch non plus
ils ont été élus parfaitement
démocratiquement qu'est ce que ça change
on a là on a le droit de dire que dans
notre conception des sociétés
démocratiques que dans notre conception
des sociétés occidentales dans notre
conception des sociétés européennes
nous sommes opposés à ce type de rien ou
peu ça c'est revenu mais on peut donner
des réponses ont redonné les devants
cette question qu'on me pose est ce
exact mais ce furent là il fait d'accord
avec vous la toile et ou noir mais
pourquoi les hongrois vote pour encore à
son bord balle qui était de gauche il
convient maintenant elle est aujourd'hui
ce qu'il est moi qui suis un fidèle
lecteur du figaro vox contrairement à ce
qu'ont écrit souvent à ce que des
intervenants du fédéraux vox écrivent
souvent on a le droit de critiquer
monsieur savini on a le droit de
critiquer monsieur joaquín où on a le
droit de ne pas penser comme eux ait été
brisée et on a le droit aussi à
l'horizon encore autour de 7 à avancer
autrement en fait de jouer le combat
contre les polices pad est certain qu'on
a en france ou en france si vous voulez
mais je réponds pas avec 102 avec
emmanuel macron absolument pas dit une
bêtise historique
on y reviendra mais il n'a pas dit une
bêtise politique effectivement il le
fait c'est une stratégie
il est en campagne pour les européennes
pas sûr qu'ils fassent progresser la
paix en déclarant la guerre à ses
voisins italiens ont mois
la gaffe a déclaré on est grand alors
que c'est lui qui pour le coc qui divise
l'europe et qui insulte quand même les
peuples en les traitant de l'épreuve
donc ça c'est une chose dont je suis pas
sûr que matic mans c'est extrêmement fin
donc ils préfèrent faire campagne pour
les européennes que d'être dans la
stature de président de la république
aux deux au dessus des au dessus des
partis et donc je suis pas sûr que voilà
que qui fasse progresser la paix après
sur le plan historique
il a dit une bêtise parce que je suis
désolé c'est pas le nationalisme qui a
causé la seconde guerre mondiale c'est
le totalitarisme et si on veut et on
parle de la première oui mais il a parlé
aussi des années 30 dont il a fait un
beau bouquet boulga
incroyable et aujourd'hui si elles
menacent totalitarisme elle n'est pas du
côté de durban ou de salvini qui est-ce
qui aujourd'hui tuer des juifs parce
qu'ils sont juifs en france qui ait ce
qui tue des européens parce qu'ils sont
européens il me semble pas que ce soit
les populistes et narbonne et l'allée
franchement il a noyé passé il en
parlant de manipulation des religieux
dans sur cette question
non on a cru donc je me rends n'a crû
que l'homme sait combien on a cru que
l'un d'eux sémitisme d'extrême droite
était en recul et on est en voie de
disparition
on se rend compte qu'en occident c'est
moins vrai qu'on a cru dans soyez soyez
prudent sur cette question l'arnage de
choyer prévu ni casser la gueule à
déjouer on n'a pas cru qu'il a nommés
parce qu'on a juste reconnu alexander
exiger des collabos et désaccords de
fond sur la nation mais me semble
incroyablement juste il faut le répéter
c'est à dire que parce que il faut quand
même qu'on raisonne de façon de façon
saine
le national le nationalisme dallas mais
le nationalisme disons d'avant guerre
était un nationaliste ou de conquête
aujourd'hui le nationaliste guide
international histoire et des vph de
défense et gars je ne l'apprécient pas
mais ils ne représentent bien évidemment
pas le même danger et alexandre a raison
de rappeler que ce qui menace pour
l'essentiel pardonnez moi de faire cette
généralité mais nos compatriotes juifs
aujourd'hui sont pas en droit on sait
très bien que ce sont les terroristes
islamistes leur a dit que voilà
oui mais dans le discours convenu elle
m'a conseillé par dont emmanuel macron a
parfaitement noyer le poisson il y avait
dedans ils atteignent phrase sur la
manipulation des religions et je ne sais
plus qui nous a parlé d'ailleurs on
était au même débat maurice de bolton à
rodez évangéliste à ma connaissance il
ya pas eu d'attentât de campagne
d'attentats évangélistes où que ce soit
dans le monde donc il ya un moment il ya
c'est quand même difficile non pardon ya
13 malgré que sa phrase épinglée stamm
est un - progrès au contraire dans son
évolution sur la façon dont elle peut
faire faillite
il a découvert il a découvert une étoile
et bientôt il verra la grèce
mais jouer me poser je voulais vous
poser des questions
ce qui est extraordinaire à aucun moment
vous dites c'est une opération politique
du raid en attendait à aucun moment vous
n'aimez telle hypothèse que peut-être
peut-être comme ça
oui le corps politique oui il croise qui
dit croire alors il y avait un moment
c'est une aberration défini sienne mais
peut-être qu'ils croient sale tête mais
à ce moment là il a une vision
anachronique et je lui rappellerai que
dans les années 30 c'est la faiblesse
face justement à la montée de certaines
idéologies qui nous a conduit à la
guerre ensuite ce qui a conduit aussi à
la guerre dans les années 30 c'est le
capitalisme financier dérégulé c'est
bien pour ça qu'après la guerre on a
fait nos modèles sociaux modèles sociaux
qu'aujourd'hui lui et ses amis veulent
détricoter
donc voilà je finis alex janvier les
jeunes qui veulent mettre j'assume ce
qu'ils veulent mettre des limites à
cette montée d'une certaine idéologie et
des limites à une mondialisation qui
détruit les modèles sociaux et le modèle
des lignes culturel ceux qui veulent
mettre des limites à cela sont à mon
avis aujourd'hui dans le camp de la paix
et non pas dans celui de la guerre vous
avez la crème jaune et arrêtons ou et le
camp de la guerre franchement je dire
arrêter il n'y a pas deux camps de la
guerre simplement est-ce qu'on peut
quand même dire un mot il ya derrière il
ya quand même un pacifisme un peu de
gens qui y est chez makro voilà yal'idée
non mais par exemple je suis désolé
maurice si j'en crois ce que je lis dans
cet estimable journal qui est le figaro
c'est bien pour faire plaisir à madame
merkel que nous avons décidé de célébrer
pacifisme sanctionnant pas si on
célèbrera si on célèbre une victoire
militaire
quand on est en et passons tout souvenir
militaire c'est une forme
ces deux caps la resocialisation
peut-être la réconciliation mais on
construit pas la réconciliation sur la
réécriture de l'histoire je suis désolé
que c'est un non sens des partis font
usage laxisme bon je vais juste alors je
le dis très vite je pense que à force de
célébrer l'amitié franco allemande que
je ne conteste pas sur tous les tons si
vous voulez l'amitié c'est très bien
mais c'est pas ça qui régit les
relations entre les peuples
on n'a plus aucun rapport de force et
fin qui m'inquiète c'est qu'en réalité
j'aimerais qu'on puisse critiquer aussi
un certain nombre d'exigences allemande
par année sur la gestion de l'euro sur
voilà or j'ai l'impression pour
l'instant que comme hollande macro nous
a dit vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir et que au delà des grandes 2 2 dès
le début j'ai trouvé ça très bien qu'ils
aient tous ces chefs d'état je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il aurait vertement allons
d'abord on laisse le dernier mot à deux
internautes on est très participatif ici
babineau qui nous dit sur le chat du
figaro on peut aimer son pays sans être
nationaliste et aulas qui reprend les
propos d'alexandre vécu en disant macron
dénonce des pays dits populiste en
traitant les gens de l'épreuve il faut
arrêter de parler comme ça même s'il
faut être précis c'était c'était la
lettre voilà c'était public qui était
considéré comme la wii et ses dirigeants
on comprenait bien on était et est élu
démocratiquement y obliger mais pas
juste c'est insultant pour des pays qui
sont voisins qui sont des alliés depuis
très longtemps des dictateurs que c'est
celui qui dit vie ont été éludées north
ont commencé pendant matin
à cette interview on a un qui n'est pas
un dictateur nous allons prendre un
exemple d'un de ses leaders qui
peut-être est considéré dans l'esprit de
mener macro comme un populiste et donald
trump donc donald trump à son arrivée
vous